so college swimming has been in the news
and not simply because it's an
interesting athletic contest riley
gaines is a college swimmer from
kentucky she's biologically female at
the women's 200 meter freestyle event at
the ncaa swimming championships the ncaa
forced gains to compete against a
biological male called leah thomas
you're seeing that race on your screen
now
remarkably gaines tied thomas despite
the obvious disadvantage for fifth place
but she says the ncaa has badly
mishandled virtually every aspect of
this competition we've been trying for
months to get college swimmers on the
show to talk about what they think about
what's happening none have accepted
except riley gaines we're grateful for
that she joins us now riley gaines
thanks so much for coming on um so i'll
just let you talk tell us what you think
of your experience at this event
yeah hi tucker thank you so much for
having me and just giving me this
opportunity to speak for myself and so
many other women athletes out there who
you know aren't as fortunate as me and
have kind of been told they're not
allowed to talk about it and so thank
you so much for that but yeah like you
said
me and leah just recently tied at the
ncaa championships
and honestly i think the ncaa handled
everything extremely poorly
starting from when we finished and i
went behind the podium to
collect my fifth place trophy and you
know they kind of blatantly told me that
leo would hold the fifth place trophy
and that i could pose with the sixth
place trophy um for photos um and would
be mailed a fifth place trophy in the
mail
so so not only are they allowing a
biological male to compete in a women's
competition they're promoting that male
over biological females who are
competing that's what i'm reading from
what you said
right um and when i kind of questioned
it you know i asked him is there a
reason why you're giving leah the trophy
he just explained to me that we're
giving it in chronological order and i
questioned him again you know what does
that mean we tied what are we being
chronological about
and he kind of blatantly said we're just
gonna give the trophy to leah we respect
and admire your swim but leah needs to
hold the trophy
in other words shut up don't ask
questions really
yeah
right i was shocked and i know all the
other swimmers
who were standing by and listening to
this were also shocked and i was
standing right next to leah and she
heard it all and so it was kind of just
really baffling that
this could happen and i know the ncaa
wasn't prepared for a situation like
this
which just tells me
when they were faced with it
they protected such a small minority and
turned their back on you know what the
organization and title ix really stands
for
well i mean they just eliminated what it
stands for it does seem to a non-swimmer
who knows that swimming requires a lot
of torture i mean nothing harder than
swing practice as you know this seems
like cheating to allow someone with a
biological advantage to compete
exactly um i think there's you know a
difference between
your sex and your gender identity and so
i think that
it's just been totally misconstrued and
lost um you know in the past
couple years or so but it's you know
finally gotten to the point where it's
being
shown and it's completely violating
women and women's rights especially in
sports
so you said a minute ago that you you're
speaking tonight on behalf of a lot of
other female swimmers who've been told
not to say a word just be quiet and be
eliminated
what do they think if you could speak
for them
right
i know just solely off talking to
tons and tons of ncaa swimmers that
their athletic directors or their
media people or their coaches or other
outside influences have told them you
know don't say anything just avoid the
situation you know save face a little
bit and i'm just fortunate enough to
where i have such an amazing support
system at the university of kentucky um
whether that be from the athletic
director all the way down to my head
coach lars jorgensen
but just speaking for them it's just
it's just totally wrong
and i know i can't speak for everyone
but i am almost certain i'm speaking for
a large majority of female athletes um
that this is just not okay and it's not
fair and you know we're dealing with
something that's completely out of our
control when we're racing you know
biological males
whether that be they have you know
different lung capacities their height
obviously testosterone levels whether
you be on testosterone blockers or not
it doesn't suppress you know going
through puberty as a male um especially
you know the one in question who swam
three years as a male
um on u-pin so it just it's just
completely unfair and it's a matter of
equity really
yeah i mean what we're seeing is
cheating and it's remarkable that it
takes bravery to point that out but it
does and you are brave for doing it and
we appreciate it riley thank you very
much well thank you yeah thank you so
much
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight